[Music]
hey
here we are you've got the volume on
turn it off turn it off
like an endless [ __ ] spiral of
[ __ ] i know it's gonna be like one of
those like endless recursion kind of
things exactly
remember like back in the old days when
you used to call a radio station
and they tell you to turn off your radio
because it would cause like that really
weird like
distortion noise or whatever yeah back
when radio existed well yeah
it's still around it's still around but
it's like and i'm sure people still call
in for concert tickets
but we did a radio show in l.a
okay [ __ ] it was like on one of their
bigger [ __ ] stations
and it had absolutely zero [ __ ]
impact
we did win on npr radio and it had zero
impact well the thing about the one we
did in la we did that with steve mara
yeah and it seemed like i think we've
talked about this before
they asked us to come on there like to
talk about uh
you know paranormal [ __ ] like
poltergeist and everything yeah and then
they just there was three hosts and they
just started talking among themselves
yeah basically making sports yeah sports
and fart jokes and [ __ ]
and we were like and they asked us like
maybe two questions and i was not
not even like i barely remember talking
on this yeah
and then they wanted us back we said
they were just idiots but i was just
like do we even need to be here
yeah and i talked to the dude to talk to
them dude before the show
because we just set the whole thing up
yeah that's right and he seemed like a
totally normal
guy yeah i'm really into the power that
was so weird that's what he was so weird
about yeah and then when
when i got on there it was like one of
those daily morning [ __ ]
zany yeah it was like a morning zoo kind
of [ __ ] yeah
stern ripoff [ __ ] [ __ ] like all they
talked about was sports
well i think waste of time i think what
ended up happening was that one guy was
like super jazzed about it and then
and then like because it was like it was
like three or four other people yeah
like so i feel like he got the people on
and then they were just like yeah okay
whatever but then they just talked among
them yeah and then the guy was like that
was great can you guys come back on i
was like no
i was like did i even say it you know i
think i maybe said once you want to do
that show again dude this is a big show
and i was like
nah no thanks and they made no impact
and then like npr
[ __ ] did a thing on mammoth mountain
no impact
although i had i got a couple of
messages of people that heard you on
there that brought the book because of
that
yeah that's not enough though yeah i'm
just saying that some people that are
we could go on a podcast and [ __ ]
sell 10 [ __ ] books in a [ __ ] hour
in a fun
[ __ ] podcast without the need of a
multi-billion dollar [ __ ] mpr
with all their radio towers and [ __ ] and
their [ __ ] massive reach
they don't buy from you yeah just don't
buy which like i said that reminds me
tomorrow night at 8 00 p.m
est i'm doing uh conspira normal it's
not just me it's like a whole bunch of
others i analyzed it you know
the the reason why they don't buy is
because mass media is just that
it's massive amounts of people it's not
targeted well it's always better to
target things
yeah that are already interested in your
target you know our [ __ ]
audience is [ __ ] targeted for us you
know the kind of [ __ ] that
we're into so you guys buy [ __ ]
general public doesn't give a [ __ ]
yeah you know they're thinking about
other things well yeah you're only going
to get i mean you're going to get people
that are just listening to it in the car
and they're not really invested they
just wanted
something in the background you know
that only worked 25 years ago
20 years ago pre-internet you know
and uh when everyone was forced to
consume
mass media we didn't have any other
choice there was no other choice
because then you guys wouldn't be able
to find us on the internet you'd be at
home forced to listen to mass media
so then you go oh man them people are
cool it might be 10 000 people
it might be a hundred thousand people
you don't know so you got a big
score back in the old days doing that
not anymore
it's all online i was laughing at fourth
drawer down saying uh
first two callers get tickets to super
trip yeah exactly
what are they talking about well that's
the thing it's like it's kind of like
uh we always listen to like classic rock
at
you know where i worked so it's like i
always kind of heard it then but i
haven't listened to it since then
yeah um yeah california's [ __ ] on
fire my cousin [ __ ]
tried to move somewhere safe in
california i was like no
wesley wesley and lois they tried to
move somewhere safe in california and i
was
they really can't find anywhere [ __ ]
safe in california they're going to end
up moving to
somewhere in the south eventually i
would think
but that it's that whole place is
falling apart world's falling apart into
the world
yeah yeah end of the world uh so anyway
uh happy labor day
uh i actually went for a walk this
morning about quarter seven and it
didn't make me want to kill myself like
you know the heat
it's kind of coming down it wasn't cool
but it wasn't
uh sweltering either which you know i
was like hey it's actually sort of
feels like fall in florida at least
so here's what we did we
wanted to watch another new movie last
night uh shutter hadn't added any new
ones that we hadn't already seen
netflix has a couple new ones but i
haven't got around to them yet and
actually one of them i'm not going to
watch
because i'm going to do a book review of
the book that it's based on and i'm
going to probably talk about it on that
but uh we did find one that was on to be
now initially
we were going to do vikings versus
krampus because i was like that sounds
funny we should start watching that so
we started watching that and it was
short it's only like an hour and 17
minutes
yeah so we started watching that and
then about like seven minutes in and we
were both like
10 minutes it was not funny
mango badger said that at 10 000 subs
the show's gonna [ __ ] take off
i don't really know where you're getting
that i think it's gonna [ __ ] grow at
the same steady rate
unless you hit 10 000 and for some
reason they change the algorithms on you
but i don't know i think it's just going
to be because it's consistently just
been growing at the same
rate it has usually i get between 180 to
200 subscribers a month average
um one thing that it that helps with the
algorithm
algorithms though is that youtube is
trying to get more channels that are
like that have like a more active fan
base or like more engaged with uh the
stuff
so it's like they will put you higher up
in the algorithms if you have more
likes and if you have more like comments
yeah so a lot of
people will say yeah you know like hit
the like button comment
on the right on the [ __ ] and everything
like that because that does
actually help i'm kind of hoping yeah
that it'll get bigger when we get to ten
thousand we're getting there
yeah but yeah so uh as fun as we thought
vikings versus krampus was going to be
it seemed like uh its alternate title
was pagan warrior and probably they
should have stuck with that because i
was thinking it was going to be like a
wacky
like funny you know what i mean but it
wasn't funny and i was just like man i
don't think i'm in the mood for this
so uh so i went and it looked like
something that
people from the renaissance fair i mean
the krampus [ __ ] looked kind of cool and
his voice sounded kind of cool and stuff
but it's just like i don't know
the edit was too long touch and then
they started doing [ __ ] weird viking
[ __ ] yelling and
then we're like yeah i was just kind of
like i don't think i'm in the mood for
this [ __ ] right now
so yeah so i had to look for another uh
horror movie that wasn't horribly long
because i was like pretty tired
so i settled on this one which is called
all the wrong
friends now it's actually not listed as
a horror movie it's actually listed as a
thriller which i guess it sort of is but
it kind of goes like in a more slasher
movie direction toward the end it's kind
of structured more like a slasher movie
than like a thriller you know what i
mean because like young characters
getting picked out one by one
so basically this is uh the debut film
of two guys named ryan hawkins and mark
karens and uh what happens in this movie
is there's a group of uh kind of
unlikable
douche bags and there i guess they all
knew each other in high school now the
movie is set in 1998 i don't think
there's any particular reason for that
other than
it's just much easier to write a horror
movie when everyone doesn't have cell
phones
and there is like a big plot um you know
the fact that they don't have a phone is
like a big and then it turns out that
the douchiest of the group
logan um he takes them like on a
detour because he's like hey we have to
go to my friend's house
like he lives out in the middle of
nowhere we have to get some stuff
and by stuff he means drugs all the
drugs
he wants to go to this guy's house the
guy's name is mondo
which i thought was very funny to go get
some drugs before they go to this uh
thing so they get to the house mondo
does not seem to be there however
logan is just like ah it's all good man
he doesn't mind if i like get into his
booze stash and his drug stash and we'll
just like stay here for the night of
party and all this other kind of [ __ ]
now most of people are kind of like yeah
i don't like that but a couple of other
ones were like drugs count me in
so then it comes to pass later on
that they find poor old mondo dead
in the bathroom upstairs he has been
murdered
so from this point forward
it almost becomes kind of like
the kind of thing where they're all like
starting to suspect one another
um and then like two hikers show up one
of them's wounded and then so they're
starting to expect those people and
those people suspect these people
and then some of the other people start
like of the original group start
dying so in that way it's kind of like a
slasher maybe
um but not exactly because it's not like
stabbing or anything like that people
just get hit with shovels or shot or
whatever it is
so this is mostly this was an okay movie
i didn't mind it
um i kept it kept me entertained like
the people in
it um were all the acting was decent
the characters were not all that likable
and were kind of
stupid um but they weren't stupid in
an unbelievable way they were stupid in
the way that here's like a bunch of
college age
drug addicts essentially or like
burnouts
that find a dead body and they don't
know what the [ __ ] to do they don't want
to call the cops because it's like you
know we have all these drugs here and
we'll get in trouble and
so they're so it just like escalates you
know because they don't want to call the
cops and they don't you know
so they can't get out of the situation
and they're not really bright enough to
figure out another way to get out of it
so in that sense like i said not a
fantastic movie
but i was entertained pretty much
through the whole thing i have to say
like i was kind of interested to see
like who the killer was going to be
and who was going to turn up dead next
and what the [ __ ] was going on and who
had killed the first guy
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so i saw
the movie as competently made but yeah
but nothing special
well yeah it wasn't like fantastic it
didn't really pull me into it
it was just kind of more of the same it
didn't stick out for being bad i'll give
it that
all right it was just a competently made
movie it didn't stick out as being great
either it was kind of
in some ways mediocre yeah um
i wouldn't have would i rewatch it now
no no
but i'm i'm sure um this guy has there's
potential
it seemed a lot better than the viking
one that we started watching
the problem was the story just the
story's not that interesting just
yeah it was basically like a bunch of
idiots find their friend dead and
there's drugs everywhere so they don't
want to get in trouble so they get into
like more and more
complex scrapes and like i said there's
there's some good
um there's like a germ of a good idea in
there of you know
as far as like the relationships between
all the people like how fractured they
are and how
there's all this kind of [ __ ] going on
between so they all like suspect one
another
um so i thought that was like really
kind of cool and like i said there's
kind of a mystery element to it so it's
kind of like a mystery
slasher s kind of movie um but yeah like
you said it's
you know it's their debut film i think
the two directors had made um
shorts prior to this the weird thing
about it is that when i looked this
movie up
to be has it listed as 2020 like it just
came onto the streaming platform like
maybe a month or two
ago but when i looked it up like on imdb
it said 2016.
so this might be a case where a movie
got made because this
seems to happen a lot with like movies
that are listed as 2020
and then when i look them up it turns
out that they were made like a couple of
years ago
it's just that the filmmakers had been
like taking them around to festivals and
[ __ ] like that until it took
until like you know a production company
came along or like a distribution
company came along
and actually got them on a streaming
platform so people can see the [ __ ]
so i think that this was made in 2016
but it just got a wide release
like just recently so like i said it's
it's not fantastic but it's pretty
entertaining like i wasn't bored like
through the whole thing and it's not
super long i think it's only like an
hour 20 minutes hour 25 years something
like that
um so you know if you're looking for
something to do like and you've watched
everything else that's on tubey which i
don't
i don't know how you would have done
that because there's 40 bajillion
[ __ ] horror movies on there like
probably
it's probably 65 percent of which i just
played garbage
it's not like it's a movie that you have
to avoid or anything it's just yeah yeah
just not something i've got on my way to
recommend it's just like i said
and it's it's competently made it's just
it's a boring story
to me yeah you know i'm jaded i you know
like i said if you like slasher movies
you might be into it although it's not
real gory no you know what i mean like
there's there's gunshots
out to me right it just was kind of like
more of them
i think you know for a first movie it's
good it's real good yeah i mean i just
need to make more movies you know
you know but this isn't my kind of movie
mango badger says stupid people are a
requirement for horror movies
how we i would really like to go back
through like all the horror movies that
i like
and kind of analyze which ones
actually are still scary but didn't
necessitate people doing stupid [ __ ] in
order for the plot to get
like hey let's go into this dark alley
like looking for this
let's go to this haunted house instead
of just walking in hearing a ghost and
being like yeah nope i'm out
and then movie end you know what i mean
it always
that's why i like ones where they they
put like the the protagonist in a
confined situation where like they
they have to be there for a certain
reason you know what i mean because then
that way there's they don't have to
necessarily
do anything stupid like everybody in
this movie like pretty much did stupid
[ __ ]
yeah so yeah that's all i can really see
take that as you will yeah yeah that's
what i'm saying about it we can't really
talk about this much longer
yeah and uh well yeah we've already been
going on for 18 minutes and you would
already
he didn't realize what time it was so he
started making that get back in there
and cook
and then i was like hey we gotta go live
you get in here so it's like all right
so we're gonna go
and make a pizza yeah and uh we'll be
back what's today monday it's labor day
right okay so we'll be back tomorrow
talking about another movie or doing a
side track show whatever it is that we
uh decided to do so it'll probably be
around 3 p.m just like usual so we'll
talk to you guys again tomorrow thanks
for dropping by as always
see ya